all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the show where you learned comedy
from the pros this is hot breath live
comedians on skype talking comedy this
is the show where you get to ask your
favorite comedians your favorite
questions so if you're watching this on
YouTube we are doing all of this live in
our Facebook group so go into the
description click join the Facebook
group so you can connect and ask
questions to your favorite comedians
like today's guest who's one of my
personal favorite comedians we were
fortunate enough to interview her last
year while she was passing through
Atlanta and now we were fortunate enough
to have her back to answer your question
so welcome back to the hot breath averse
the one and only Beth Stelling ladies
and gentlemen welcome Beth Stelling to
the show thank you for having me well
welcome back Beth so what is he I'm
sorry I got I got so excited I cut you
off that is a great sign of an
interviewer I'm already excited cutting
off the guests thank you so I've been
starting these off because everyone's
having a different experience with like
the quarantine and just especially in
the comedy world everyone has has like a
different approach to how we're
surviving and maintaining what it what
is what has been your quarantine life
like and have you been able to maybe
even sustain your comedy through this
I'm subsisting mostly off of sugar the
grocery link yeah you can't go that
often you know I may try to limit it
until I need to go to the grocery and I
look in my little cart and I'm like this
is 100% candy I'm not what you expect
but yeah I think I'm it's to the point
where I am or I want to say I'm more
productive than I give myself credit for
I think that's a issue I had before the
quarantine I think it's like I'm
handling this out like I'm very careful
with my word choice because this is a
pandemic it's a very difficult time
family all over the country mostly in
the Midwest and everyone of course is
dealing with it differently and
depending on your job you may be really
suffering so I you know the humor in it
I suppose is I'm quarantine alone so
every life choice I've made up to this
point has been really incredible my
husband and beautiful self curated
apartment so you know it's one of those
things where if this I think about
comics of course and I think about if
this had happened to me right when I
first moved here I mean I would have
been working several jobs it would have
been am i still working for this family
or they sell foreign tini am i working
at this cafe that becomes an essential
you know like it would have been a
really scary time so I feel for people
who just moved to LA to follow their
dreams and now they're dealing with not
being able to pay rent and my goodness I
remember that when I did first move
there was a writer's strike with the WGA
and I remember thinking almost like Oh
perfect timing
little did I know that would be zero
issue for me I mean like here and you're
like oh no I'm not gonna be able to join
the WGA right away it's like babe it's
gonna be like a lot of years before yeah
so I think it's just like I'm happy to
be where I am obviously she give myself
credit I've worked very hard to each
Miriam but thankfully my job as a writer
I can write from my office right here
did I talk for a long time oh that's
this is a Q&A with you you're supposed
to be talking it's fine don't worry I
know I cut you off and then and then I
let you talk and you're like wait when's
he cutting me off you know but she has
the dog that she's got Nigel but in
general yes
I think I feel I'm feeling similar to
probably have a lot of people who work
from home are feeling you know like a
little mixture of insane and little
Groundhog Day a little time is flying a
little time is going very slow and now
for LA it seems that we have extended
our stay at home orders until August so
that's news
it's good you could still work though
cuz a lot of comics are like scrambling
to figure out a lot of comics like oh I
better start that podcast now like
everyone's just some people are just
freaking out yeah they are a lot and
that's the other thing too like I'm not
someone I don't know I there's like you
know some good content getting put out
and I think there's some so content that
might be deleted here quality over
quantity I always have been but I just
think we really gotta think I I'm more
just like think I guess before you put
out cuz I realized we're experiencing a
lot of that I think there's a lot of
discord of course between the haves and
have-nots right now there's sort of like
we're all in it together and it's like
you're fine your movie being closed and
other people can't
it's freaking Queen and ran to feed
their children so I think it's just it's
an important time as a comment to always
stay in touch with what's going on in
the country but it's sort of parallel to
what it's like when a comic gets famous
and loses his touch with them round and
it starts talking about things that they
cannot relate to so you didn't like
thinking of comics that have like made
it and in our first interview we talked
about your experience working with Judd
Apatow I would like to learn a little
bit more about you getting to work with
Sarah Silverman who is of that same ilk
of comedian that is like in the holy
grail of comedy minds and comedy greats
can you even share your experience
working with her what it's like what
you've learned like as the your
experience with Judd was very
informative so I I
wanted to get into like Sarah as well
yeah um Sarah's a you know one of the
best comedians in the world she's what
she's one of my favorites and also one
of my favorite people to work for you
know pitch bits to and she's a great
boss so she's she's I guess I can't say
enough good things about Sarah Silverman
you know she's someone who's been around
for for many years because she started
when she was a teenager and she's you
know I in the last breath I mentioned
comics who are out of touch and sort of
can't you know keep an audience because
they're no longer able to connect with
them she's not that at all you know
she's not the person sending someone to
go do things for her she does them
herself so she can remain in touch with
life but I learned a lot from Sarah you
know I'm grateful to having become
friends with her over the last since I
you know last I guess nine years since I
moved here and I think it's one of those
things like one of the main things I
learned from watching her especially
when we were touring she was trying to
speck of dust and I was getting ready
for my half hour on Netflix so listen
about three years ago
um was opening for her on the road and
one of the things I loved about watching
her and it's a good reminder for me and
I still struggle with this it's funny
how it's hard to change but I watch her
and she performs each show like it's the
first time she's telling those jokes so
she's very present and in that same vein
she's a wonderful actress because that
is part of stand-up is a performance and
act you know I think some people for the
longest time just like they think at
Midnight's on the spot they think
stand-ups on the spot and it's like a
lot of these jokes for him over time
especially I I think back to audiences
three years ago when I was starting to
rebuild this hour that I just filmed and
I'm like sorry guys oh wait some of
those jokes didn't make sense
some of them are bad or problematic and
now they're what I meant to say like
it's they were filled with moral you
know unnecessary words that I've since
cut out just don't need to say so from
watching her she's just been she's a
well-oiled machine
you know she eats she knows her voice
and I think she goes to great lengths to
remain in touch with her audience and
people and evolve over time you know
she's the writing for I Love You America
I will say I came on to what they called
season one because who wouldn't give
them a season two because then they
would have to up everyone's contracts
and pay so they kind of wash I see about
that
it was season one B which I came on for
and I left I just came from good boys
set in Vancouver and I went to I love
you America for those I forgot whatever
it was twelve weeks or something and in
really I was just again more on set
punch up and monologue so a lot of the
work on I Love You America is done by a
team that was formed long before me and
as brilliant that writing team as she
put together is filled with awesome
people and I had someone done before and
others I got to know in the show and she
assembled a really brilliant team of
writers it's a perfect mix of silly and
smart and passionate they've all they
all go on to continue to work because
they're great is there any advice you've
gotten from her from getting to work
with her so much that you just kind of
will never forget hmm
I mean at this point you know there are
personal life lessons that I learned and
we discuss and share and her experiences
I would say you know this isn't
necessarily something new but the idea
that all of this is so long it's it's
not a it
not a sprint it's along the long road
you know so you have to keep that in
mind with your ups and downs I think
that's something she's good at reminding
me of that you know you're gonna have
disappointments and things that you fall
short and failures and you're here to
stay
you know I think that's a fear that you
have for a long time that you fail and
you're gone but it's like they gave
what's that woman's name and hache like
three television shows like certain
people get many many chances and I think
that does it just because you might not
be as well-known of a writer doesn't
mean that you won't have more than one
chance to you know it's not it's not as
make-or-break as that phrase that is set
as a major break you know it's like it's
the same thing like when people say this
is your big break it's like I've been
breaking for the last seven years
yeah he was on here
a week or two ago and he had talked
about like Netflix not picking him up
and he was like you gotta be in a
wheelchair like you know he had a funny
joke about it but it's like yeah but it
does seem like and this is interesting
timing because you just taped your hour
we just had Ted Alexandro on here
yesterday who is like he almost like
started the independent way back in like
the 90s who was releasing independent
specials so it's like you recording an
hour
what it are you planning to sell it has
someone already bought it
what is everyone has is seemingly having
trying to figure out this new Netflix
isn't buying everything anymore so what
is next so what is what is your strategy
behind the new hour special so for me I
did my half hour on Netflix I mean it's
always been a dream of mine to have an
HBO special I think it's kind of I don't
want to say excuse me I just
you know um tell that sugar-sweet bath
anybody oh can you see it Oh in that
weird this is my coffee shop I used to
manage in Chicago everybody should buy
their beans from dollop yum small
commercial anyway so did my have I was
yes it was a dream of mine to be have an
HBO special I think similarly to mark I
was in you know discussions with them
and back I'm horrible at time maybe two
years ago or a year ago I have no clue
and they came and saw me and to be
honest I would say what they saw is not
like it depends on what they see and
some right like for me I'm I would say
I'm more sensitive to my surroundings
then maybe most in the sense that I
would prefer you see me in a certain
place a certain Club you know like I
feel like I shine when I'm comfortable
and as cheesy as it sounds I feel safe
and I know that those you know like I
guess this is sort of stating the
obvious like if you're a certain comic
you want them to come see you at your
favorite venue but some comments feel
like you should kill everywhere and it's
like well I can do my job technically
everywhere but my comfortability will
shine through in my performance I you
know I think there's certain times as a
comic where you can really feel your I
mean genius is a bit hyper Paulo
hyperbolic but you can feel your genius
flowing through you it's a flow you know
where you can't describe it what you're
like yeah
most people would say I was just on or
it was just a good set you know but
there were times when you walk away and
you're like that was cool
like I he wasn't trying I just let it
happen and then other times where it
feels very plotting and and like you
were off and it's something you're mad
at yourself and I think this particular
Club they came in saw me had I just it's
not my faith it was more very club' and
people who were not you can feel the
percentage of who
vibing you just showed up for her for
what they wanted to see or a comedy show
and this particular hour I would say Q
is something I feel very passionate
about and put a lot of time and energy
to but the place they call came and saw
that hour I was more on the side of
angry then where I've got you to which
is funny so I think that played a role
this is all to say that there's a lot
taken over time with them and eventually
HBO max came to light that they would be
launching this new streaming service
with a lot of original content and then
of course the whole friends catalog and
everything that you I don't know if
you've seen promos yeah that they're
offering like 1199 a months for the
first year so then basically HBO max
came in with an offer that I could not
refuse and Team Coco they had brought
them on to produce them and obviously
I've worked with Conan and done Conan a
couple times and close with them and
have a good relationship and so when it
came time for them to curate their
stand-ups for HBO max which they put
them in charge of they wanted to work
with me so I don't I didn't describe
that as concisely as I would have liked
to say I really went off on I as a
writer your word economy is really we
got to tighten these up here let's let's
go back now I'm just kidding Beth no
it's all relevant though because I was
acting you were giving context to where
the landscape of comedy specials are and
to where they're headed and you're being
a part of these new frontier of
platforms that are diving into the
comedy specials no I mean think about it
some cut like a great comic like Brent
Weinbach years ago put out a special and
see so it's like it could have been huge
it or it could have been
what happened which is there's no see so
anymore so it's just like Brent's a
great comment he's brilliant you never
know what's gonna happen when you enter
into something new it's a risk but for
me it's a risk I wanted to take because
obviously I'm hoping that it's going to
be big and there will be a large
audience for it you know even more so
than then what I guess you would call
regular HBO because if you look at the
numbers on that they're not always as
big as you think they would would be you
know their age yeah so I'm hoping that
so my special will come out on HBO max
in August is the is the answer if you'd
like to cut out everything I've just
said the last quarter minute
oh no we're live this is it it's all
it's all relevant don't worry Beth yeah
we're all I mean we you have to you know
like mark I'm sure was saying it's like
you have hopes for who you want to take
it and they might say no and so
sometimes you have options and other
times you don't Darris troit there's
stories like that for every comic
there's stories like that for famous
comics like they didn't want them they
weren't big enough at the time where
their career took the dip I mean we
could be talking about somebody like Ray
Romano's was on Netflix oh I don't I
don't know his personal story I'm just
saying he could have gone to them and
said hey I want to do special and I said
no and then he went with a smaller
company or whatever it is like epics or
something and that did well so then he
can do his next special with Netflix or
HBO or whatever that's not his story
he's on Netflix and it was a great
frequenting special but I'm just saying
like this it can happen to anybody it
doesn't just have to be these look like
a no-name comic that didn't like mark
calls himself went on famous comic it
could have happened him and it could
happen - I'm trying to think of a better
example but no you're one that comes to
mind for me that is popular in his world
is like Gary Owen who's done a lot of
showtime specials but he he has talked
about Netflix won't hook me up you know
I don't know enough white people he'll
say things like that you know so I guess
he's an example of a guy who sells out
theaters and stuff but still hasn't
broken the Netflix ceiling but
it's odd because at this point part of
their drive does seem follower driven
you know so you'd think that if I'm not
sure Gary's pollen count or whatever but
I know his he's very popular and
prolific and talented so yes sometimes
it's a little bit of a wonder why they
choose what the shoes are continuing to
put money into certain things I mean if
I had to [ __ ] on them I'd say they've
ruined stand-up comedy but I think it's
one of those things where really but I
think it's like it's this idea that
everyone has that you put out an hour
every year I think some people are
actually capable of putting out quality
content per year and others I think
we've discovered well I'm I'm personally
not claiming to be one of those people
I'm not I'm a hundred percent not one of
those people that should or wants to put
out an hour every year that's another
thing I've learned from Sarah she puts
out a special cuz it's called a special
when she has something special to say or
has worked on something that she'd like
to deliver it like to me it should be a
really good product
not a podcast with four jokes but some
people are money driven and I get it
take that money get your whatever your
deal is deliver them an hour per year
some people it's like you know I can
[ __ ] on it and then if they gave it to
me and said hey we'll give you 20
million for four specials over the next
four years you're kinda like okay right
yeah I'll take your money and we'll
we'll get into these questions here and
don't worry oh people are saying CJ says
Beth she's so funny Karluk I love
listening to her she can keep talking
she's super smart
yeah people yeah people are here for you
Beth they're all in support Cody says
love from Beavercreek Ohio Oh
Bochy is it good Cody sailor no okay hi
Kelly and yeah Henry Henry river says hi
so let's get into their questions now
because okay that's why we are here as
well I selfishly have to open up with
questions as a fan but let's get into
the first one here from Tobias Taylor
Tobias says hey Beth how did you get
into comedy three girls and I my sisters
were you know I guess it's all cheesy
sounding but it's like you know my
sisters were so loving and doted on me I
was as I wasn't you know tormented by my
older siblings I was really made the
sort of center of attention in a lot of
ways and I always wanted to keep up with
them so I was trying to be probably
intellectually ahead of where I was I
think that's the benefit of being the
youngest is you kind of develop quicker
intellectually because you're trying to
keep up with the kids around you which
are your siblings so I mean I love
making them laugh so I mean those are my
origin my origin story I mean this much
of it but I guess stand-up I got into bi
encouragement for my my girlfriends in
college
I would kind of come home either from
school or work or whatever it was and
make them laugh and we just kind of you
know stand in the living room by by the
TV that's an alternate form of
entertainment and make them laugh and I
think for a while there I had another
friend in high school will Alan who had
given me a Jim Gaffigan CD burned these
were the Burton CD days and that was
really my first introduction to stand up
and I love Jim he's very talented
yeah but it's not necessarily like I
listened to that and fell in love it was
just sort of like oh this is the thing
stand-up comedy's the thing work because
I didn't grow up like listening to it or
adoring it particularly and then Dane
Cook happened and that was when I was in
college and
it was like Dane Cook was incredible we
loved him you know you have to think
about where you are and what you love at
the time and Dane was it so like you
know [ __ ] on the coats and all those
bits we were just like you know
memorizing laughing listening to in the
car so that was the first time you felt
like that was like a comedy superstar
and my formative years or introduction
to stand up so then it was almost
intimidating for me to start but I went
down to Charleston South Carolina first
balletto my friends were in a band
called Bell and they were playing and
they they were it's like I always had
these friends pushing me championing me
being like yourself funny you should do
stand-up and the transition from being
funny for your friends and to stage on a
microphone is probably the obviously the
biggest scariest step and not seamless
so they just let me open for them and
that meant me telling one of the stories
that I told them about my childhood that
made them laugh on a stage in a bar but
it was you know breaking the seal it was
terrifying and I did it and it was
exhilarating and it was bad I mean yeah
I was probably the equivalent of being
like hey honey you like telling a little
kid to tell a joke yeah
I think that's how I started stand-up
officially I suppose was in Charleston
and I same week and we wouldn't saw
Isaac witty and Amy Schumer and they
were on tour with one other comment I
feel bad I can't remember his name but
um you know honestly people say this
about me a lot I've gotten a few
mentions like I think Netflix put out a
question like who's a stand-up comic
that made you think you could do
stand-up or want to do stand-up and a
lot of but I will say that about Amy I
watched her in that festival and I was
like I can do this so I think you know
that also speaks to representation I'm
seeing a woman on stage with these guys
oh my god yeah I can do that and I was
probably like I don't know how old I was
at the time 20 keeping like that 21 and
this doesn't actually uh buh buh
Johnson's question who asks what was the
first joke Beth wrote well I think I've
told this before
hey airs getting it's getting blurred
out yeah yeah thank goodness and I put
on a ton of makeup okay gussied up for
this thank you no okay truthfully I want
to say like Oh quite well cuz cuz I was
well I've always been a mix of stories
and jokes so I'm trying to think of like
some of the earliest jokes I guess like
I've been flying since I was six cuz my
parents are the worst now first like
joke I first and I've said this before
sorry
because like I've been asked these some
of these questions before nothing and
it's just one or two we're gonna get
deeper here it's just the first okay
those thing questions don't mind her
everyone shallow questions my fans are
asking right now back to my initial
issue of when I watched Sarah and she
makes it new every time I have a huge
problem with feeling disingenuous which
like like so sometimes my stand-up if
I've performed the Joker I'll almost
start to tell it like you guys know this
one and it's like no they don't and it's
not because I think everyone knows
mirrors familiar with me it's because I
I know how many times I told it and so
I'm kind of like iliad saying it again
and I kind of throw it away so it's like
stop doing that like do it like you just
wrote it for them as opposed to like so
I feel disingenuous and the reason I say
what I just said is I've said this
before too in an interview but first
joke was a we would drive to my
grandma's in Louisville and there was a
sign for this you know exit called
nameless Creek and I said to my mom I
was like what is that
one that Lewis and Clark didn't get to
you know I think that was probably my
first like put something see something
put it together make something and then
an advert and joke was probably first
grade and my mum asked like did you have
a sub today and I said no you packed me
a peanut butter and jelly so like you
know when the kid is just like doesn't
that was probably my first inadvertent
joke but then like when it came to stand
at my jokes at that time we're very like
I remember you know your references are
like that I haven't had a Chicken Soup
for the Soul Jo joke I'm trying to give
like early jokes AirTrain alright at
airplane jokes about sitting half you
you have to pay extra to sit in the exit
row I didn't sign up to be a flight
attendant I have no clue that this is a
bad answer
can you every answer has been great that
okay and that that actually is something
we asked me and struggle with a lot in
terms of not giving rambling answers but
is to actually it's actually that making
your joke new every time and delivering
it the same way every single time like
what if what mindset do you go into the
joke with or have you found a system or
ritual that helps you to actually
deliver it like it is the first time I
still struggle I still struggle you know
I don't want to go back to the same club
a year later and give the same act and I
don't this problem and anxiety of mine
has resulted in probably more material
because I'm scared like you know I've
had people kind of come up to me like
every time I see you it's different and
I'm like to me I'm like it doesn't feel
like that but I'm so glad you're saying
that because I'm terrified of showing up
to a club every year and being the
person who's like same jokes every time
yeah well Simon
everything's a tornado in my head hot
and cold fronts meeting because you're
like you don't want to be in the comic
that does that but you also don't want
to be the comic that just shows up with
weak-ass material and it's just later
girl
out here what do you guys want to talk
about it's like you know show up so this
one can go with a chase bond and
speaking of on the topic of your jokes
what's your favorite joke you've written
new or old that's a toughy
I guess like favorite joke I've written
to come to mind I suppose I don't know
yeah I think I think newest jokes
sparked the most joy for comics
especially when they think of it try it
and it works like that's obviously to me
the greatest joy I guess up there with
making people laugh is a new joke
working or a new idea being like yes um
which is tough during these times
because we don't really have an audience
to test that out so it's been what two
months now since I filmed my special
which is the last time I perform
stand-up comedy and so I get I don't
want to ruin the joke but it's a special
it's a joke for my upcoming special
about abortion and the stigma of it
being on women when it's a two person
connection I'll tell you you're my
favorite joke of yours or I mean well
I'm a fan I love your writing but this
one was one that just stuck out to me
from your I first saw it on your conan
set in 2017 where it was oh I hate doing
someone's joke but I think these are
pretty much the words it's I don't even
weigh myself anymore I just ask someone
to draw me
and if they reach for a marker I know
they have know I've gone too far that
just it's visual and it's it's concise
and that's something um we had Jesse
David Fox on here and he talked about
his favorite jokes were are the ones
that like get a lot out in a short
amount of words like you can see it in a
short amount of words
and that's one to me that just like it
just hits and it's quick and it's just
so clever like was that one that kind of
came to mind or do you really have to
like widdle that one together over
months and months that was probably just
a come to mind thing that I was trying
with my poor Begley at the time he was
touring the new one and working on that
and shaping it and sharpening it and I
did it he and I rift together well like
in the car and stuff and so I I said
what do you think of this he's like
that's so funny
and then he pitched the if they reach
for a marker or no wait I can't remember
if he pitched the I reached for a marker
or I think I said that and then he said
if they draw a stick figure I agree I
think that's what his what his tag was I
give him credit this dude
but yeah I'd forget what it was heat we
grit we ripped that out together but
he's also going he's giving me
confidence on jokes where I'm coming
he's like yeah so awesome yeah he's
definitely with everything he's doing
online he's definitely a guest goal or a
goal guest to get on here and answer
comic questions
ah let's get into the next one which is
I love we're starting to get
chronologically through your career here
so Jason Fox asked when first starting
comedy how did you handle when sets
would bomb and what kept you going ah I
feel like those bombs probably felt
worse just so bad
I mean bummed suck hmm like after a
while I went through a period of like
honestly just not bomb me because I
wouldn't let myself and that's bad too
because you're just sort of like I don't
know I think you gotta get it push
through the ball you got a bomb to get
great I guess I mean but I really did go
through a period of avoiding bombs like
I said I think that sounds like well how
did you do that and it's like what do
you just do what you know works and you
don't really push too hard or test
anything and
you're kind of scared you're just
performing scared so wait what was the
question it was when first started
comedy how did you handle sets that
would bomb and what kept you going God I
mean how did I handle them embarrassment
like just you know you feel shame you
wanna crawl in a hole how did I handle
them I still handle probably everything
the same way just like with a bowl of
ice cream right before bed what kept
going I don't know a sick you know I
used to say like you know I guess in
stand-up it's a mix of things there's
all different kinds of us but pretty
much all the same where you kind of have
to be a little dumb okay you have to be
very smart to be a good comic I thing
into like they ask you have to have some
web in some comics you can tell us
intellectual and in other comics
I guess this I'm I'm all over the place
right now I think to be funny you had to
be smart like that's that's a fact it's
it doesn't mean school smart I'm just
saying like you have to have a sharpness
to you um I think so that sounds like
I'm saying I think you're doing great
here we're all having fun you're you're
very successful comedian that deserves
to be where you are we're grateful
you're even willing to take time out of
your important day to be here with us
all of your words hold extreme value and
relevance the question is still about
bombing oh oh oh okay so you kind of
have to be dumb though to be to think I
have something to say you know like it's
a mix cuz like I didn't start out
thinking like I'm gonna change the world
everybody must listen to me and I blow
up you have to be a little dumb
I'm gonna move to LA Oh but cuz like
part of me was like it's not that I
thought I was like I'm gonna move there
and make it be huge I just was like I
can do this and like I guess the thing
that kept me going was the fact that I
wanted to try and see if I could I mean
and they end goals goal setting I
suppose that's what kept me going I
always would write around my goals and
they've changed over time but they used
to be things like perform at comedians
you should know perform it to Lake Shore
theater a late night set you know I'll
get specific but um yeah they're just
soso goal setting and then you have it a
bit of blindness to keep going cuz if
you start doing the math on it you're
not gonna make it baby
and obviously the joy in the past and
making people laugh and your goals can
change average over time they will and
what you're going for I think it's sunk
sometimes sorry there's this girl who
lives above me is like I can hear her
dropping something weights or the
momentum of this interview this
interview bombing oh people are
commenting still love her energy someone
I'd want to hang out with there they're
encouraging you in the comments right
now Beth yeah that's fun we're all in
this together yes I think to obviously
this is like a weird time where we're
like I was saying before at the
beginning I don't know if we were
recording yet but it's like do I need to
put content out right now like is it
am I really making people's days better
if I push to put put something out or is
it best to just like kind of chill and
this is like the world is saying like
take a break here for a second um but
yeah DOM and yeah you definitely
answered that yeah just you're just like
why what do I have
to say so I think that changes over time
because I've said a lot you know I have
a good amount of things that I've put
out in this next hour for me was very
very much a passion project so you know
the morning after I filmed my special
was very cathartic you know it's like I
put so much time and energy in years
into it because it should be something
you're proud of and special and so I
think the next steps of building now I'm
back at square one where I was three
years ago and you're like I'm almost in
the place where I'm just like should you
come and see me why my me late I
shouldn't say that public but because
it's like it's not gonna be good yet so
like to me when you see a comic is is I
don't know the word I'm looking for
it really hinges on where they are and
in that portion of their material
because like technically if this special
comes out you come see me in September
if we're allowed to leave our houses
it's like is it gonna be me just trying
new material that I've written during
this quarantine I don't want to come out
and just you quarantine jokes for people
I don't think that's that's not what I
want to be putting out so it's like what
do I have to say now life has changed it
will be different yeah it's like it just
it's odd where you catch a comic in
their generation of material so even
like I said comment like seeing me just
before I film the special in Seattle
what a great show I had a blast
they were like those things those jokes
were right where I wanted them and now
do I go and be the comic that performs
the special you just watched no I think
you have to find a mix but that but
there's no boss of me except for me and
he also don't want to be the comic that
comes out I'm like what are you gonna
hear like you have to go out and be sure
so it's like I've talked to Nate
bargatze about it after so many special
and putting out and his kind of tactic
is sort of just like hey I'm gonna give
you as much new as I can
and we'll have fun and then I'll tell
some of the old stuff and then I yeah so
I think my sister will always tell me
like bad you know when you go see your
favorite musician you want to hear crazy
in love yeah you know and that's what
was funny you sang Nate because we
actually we did a Q&A with him like this
and he was talking about even someone
like at his level
who's released like a special he's like
anytime I release something I am
immediately worried that I'll never be
able to write another amazing joke as
good as what I wrote in those specials
so it's amazing like at every level
whatever the benchmark is we're always
like reverting back to oh they're gonna
find out that that was all I had but I
mean you know it's talent you know and
it just takes just takes time to develop
material but you're gonna be great
thanks so let's gets run through these a
little bit here so I wanna make sure
people get their questions and answering
like with yes or no questions all right
we could do this with yes or no because
Cody Saylor asks any plans on a show in
Dayton in the near future
yes I'm supposed to there's a Women of
Influence series happening at the human
race theater but I was supposed to come
and do this month and which is in Dayton
and and I was supposed to do a Columbus
Festival like in a couple weeks but I
don't think it's been officially
cancelled but maybe I haven't like it's
an odd time right now I'm like Jeff Tate
who's in Cincinnati was like no that's
gonna be canceled so it's like I don't
have a ticket home so I guess it's a
tough it's just a tough question to
answer because I it's pandemic related
but I want to come home and I'll do a
show at the human race theater probably
is the answer yay
yeah so Jonathan Hernandez one two
things you would do differently in your
comedy career and what's one thing you
wish you'd
knew you'd knew you'd know sorry that
was my liberal arts degree coming out
well what is this here what anyway so
what are two things you would do
differently in your comedy career and
what's one thing you wish you knew
before starting your career a yes-or-no
answer
done differently I guess a simple answer
is just when I was a new face of
Montreal out of Chicago and it was a six
minute said and you like rehearsed it
and it was that's what got me in and it
and I really stuck to it and I was
scared about sticking to the time and
I'm very much like type a rule follower
very organized comic and when I got
there it was mostly New York and LA
comics and they're all very nice and
stuff but they were just sort of like in
I might go a little over am I gonna do
new bed I'm gonna do this very relaxed
and I was like I it's not that I had I
wasn't the comic that like necessarily
stuck to a annotated or transcription or
something but it was something I worked
on lay it was it was meticulous and I
just was terrified of going over and you
know sticking to it and that makes you
more one-dimensional you know so I if I
could do it over I would say like listen
don't blow the light by ten minutes but
have fun I mean have fun is really so
I'm sick of hearing it it's it's just
like what do you do have fun that's so
stupid it's just like be in the moment
and not worry as much
so yes have fun but I'm it's bad advice
ah so that's what I would do differently
and hmm I mean you can't change these
things but the way I put out my albums
is insane some of that's not even done I
just feel like it's more like you know
feeling like you're more in charge of
your
career I think there's balance with that
there's comics that come out like right
away I'm a comic here's my card and you
know they know and they know what
they're doing and I was sort of like so
what you do your album with us we really
love it and I'm like sure you know it's
like kind of I would be less accepting I
would be more more questioning of the
things and intentions and yeah the way I
put out my albums like I said some of
those jokes were jokes I just told for a
brief period of time and then later I
finished them and put them in a special
so in some ways I kind of liked that I
did that were you listening to it on the
album and it's like that's funny and
then later you see it done in a special
that's kind of fun but yeah and then one
thing I wish I knew hmm it's hard to say
I don't know I think like I think you
said it with like just being more
mindful of some of the choices and the
people you trusted yeah things like that
that when you're young and just and like
gung-ho here we go you're just thinking
about what's gonna give me the heat or
whatnot as opposed to well what do I
want what are my what what do I want to
get out of my own comedy career and not
listen to what other people think my
career should be yeah I think it's you
know stand-up is always something where
there are no rules and there's no boss
and there's no nothing yet everyone
pretty much does the same thing they get
up and they just talk into the
microphone people hold it differently
and touch it differently
standing really but we're all doing the
same thing so it's odd how
individualistic it can be and yet people
really adhere to the boundaries so yeah
I think I'll just be more discerning and
I'm thankful for the people I've been
worked with because you know your words
are a magnet so don't say stuff that you
don't want those people
coming to you your words are a magnet
that is gold right there yeah you you
know you'll reap what you what you say
course them I'm gonna put that on a
magnet and sell it as merch all right so
let's see careful let's get let's
combine these two cuz they're similar
and it's um it'll be a two-parter here
Trent Babb asks do you write random
jokes and group them later or stick to
one theme until finished and this could
also parlay into like Wayne flake asking
what is your favorite writing techniques
so do you use random jokes and group
them together or stick them in a theme
later and what technique do you enjoy
when you're creating this material close
so I think it's no I I just write what
comes to me or things that are you know
on my mind or get stuck in my craw and
emotions and feelings and relationships
that are affecting me what's happening
to me right now is how I write and I
later find a string or a thread to weave
them all together and the dip most
typical part of that is like obviously
if I write a joke about going to
Chipotle hi it's like where does that
fit in there's always gonna be one
that's like an out layer where you're
like it's just gonna go in because I
don't have anywhere to really put it
because I'm someone who really likes to
have it flow and makes sense it's like
you know it's a script it's it's in some
ways it can be very funny to go from
talking about you know I'm looking
around my house whatever buying a new
lamp and then being like so my dad's a
dick
you know like obviously you can smash
things up together to make them funny in
that way but I also like having a be
have me flow from subject to subject and
you know how did we get from growing up
in sex ed class to Damita movement I
mean whatever like you just had to be
from here to there and and I mean you
even think about it having just flowing
with me so I I definitely string them
together consciously callbacks come
probably the latest you know as you're
putting finishing touches on it where
you're like what would blows callbacks
flowing on I mean it's his mind so if
you strategically place them that's
important and I'm willing to change and
add things up until the last minute and
the way that I write mostly is
scribbling things down in my notes on my
computer it's all threaded through
connected to my phone so it's like if I
put you know I'll do the Notes app I'll
do voice memos but I rarely go back and
listen I or record every set but I
rarely go back and listen to my voice
memos of joke ideas I need to do that
it's only to-do list that a couple of
months and write in little notebooks
everywhere so the that can be bad
because I'll go back through a notebook
after it it I'm I'm also like
instinctually editing you can say like
oh I'll look back and think like I
should have worked harder on this or
that and it's like going on the road and
over periods of months and times like I
just do it so I think I'm not working
cuz I didn't sit down and work with it
but if I listen to a set from 2017 and
then 2019 I did it just because it was
trial and error so I didn't sit down and
but I did it and so it doesn't that's
why I might that constant feeling if I
should the recognition to working it's
like by thinking about it by doing it
you're working because I just I tell I
test jokes by not open mics but I had
lying sets I mean like that's just sort
of like or local shows around LA I mean
again this is all absolutely now because
we're gonna be back but yeah sometimes
the first time you try it it's very
close to what it will be and other times
you're saying something wrong
potentially problematic until you figure
out
the missing piece that will get you to
the punchline and yeah this this coming
from
oh do you have a notebook right there
were you looking oh this is full this is
the standard notebook show all that is
all you're uh you're kind of blurred out
or you're more can you pull oh I know
can yeah I was gonna say can you pull
one up okay like that and it depends on
and then sometimes it's just like you
know angry writing but it's also a lot
of setlists you know I don't know it's I
just have to move my face
well maybe it's best that it's blurred
oh you could see the back of it so when
it's like that
oh no when you bring it up at a downward
angle it's not blurred but we can't read
it either way so we can see we could see
scribbles but like you can't read
setlist and part is just rewriting the
hour in a setlist form moving things
around and trying them in order but yeah
it's like you know it's instinctual what
you feel comfortable opening on what a
good strong joke is and how to get them
quick yeah I also just change notebook
size over time or just in different
moods or whatever so sometimes I'll be
on one of these you know and sometimes
I'll I switch I switch like sighs a lot
oh yeah and styles yeah I'll do the same
thing sometimes it's the oh there we go
it's just think I don't know I think
there oh oh there we go
sometimes little stories or what did
they write here what was it I shouldn't
really looked at that before I showed it
what it's saying well well what no this
one was fine what the top one was fine
it just said Nigel dug a hole to get to
a tray of the neighbors cornbread so the
name
put a tray of cornbread on their side of
the fence and then of course my mom's
dog dug a hole to the other side where
the cornbread was I'm like was it poison
like why are you putting cornbread by
the fence you lunatic but I think she
likes birds I'm just like you're gonna
put a corn bread on the other side
that's worried but guys what do you
think is gonna happen then he and then
she also chopped down my sister's
childhood tree because it was partly in
her yard this woman
my mom's neighbor was a psycho I never
even joked about it what so what I need
come from like you were just on the
phone with your mom and she was telling
you this so then you go and write it
down yeah people love hearing Nigel
stories I never put that really into a
joke though but I have it I don't know
maybe I'll put it in a script or
something cool and then this is this
says dad's tale which is a story from my
friend natalie lani
I I rarely like I typically just use my
own things like all of my stuff is I
can't think of something I've said that
didn't happen like of course I think I I
don't I can't speak for other comics I
think some comics are fine with making
stuff up and I think audiences in
general often believe that you're making
it up and I think sometimes stuff from
my life they think I'm making up until
they like go to my dad's website no I
owe this man is real so I think like my
stuff is real there's only one time I
took an experience of a bike riding
situation that happened my friend Aaron
but it went into my biking material film
and she's like one of my best friends so
it was like she told me what happened
and I wrote a joke about it so it's like
but anyway dad's tale I've never told
that joke but she caught it when she was
like a little girl she walked in on her
dad showering and came to her mom when
she said Papa's got a tail that's just I
know I wrote that that's great yeah and
then Forensic Files I do weird things in
my hotel now so the security cam footage
will catch me like dipping my toe in the
pool
eating three Snickers so it's fine
something about like making it and then
they
very difficult to track what happened to
me before I died I I have no clue I
think I think I was thinking of staying
in a bad hotel in Seattle because the
owner of laughs comedy club is cheap and
they didn't care where they put you they
put me in this trucker motel that was
like there was like hypodermic needles
and it was like bad and I had to talk to
other comics where he put them in a
nicer hotel so it's just like it sucks
that you know you're already I hate to
be like women earn is tough but it's
like you know as a female comic you're
already kind of more a little more
vulnerable on the road or you can we
don't make sweeping statements but you
know you're traveling alone so to stay
at this like crappy motel I was like I
should do a lot of things on the
security footage so they know I'm here
like okay you know maybe around the
place and then if I die then go for sure
know what happened before I died anyway
that's I never wrote a joke about it but
this end this thing here I'm not gonna
tell you the one that we should have
been blurred out is that what you're
saying yeah why cuz it's like is it like
gross or is it racist
[Laughter]
yeah it said a guy I dated named and
then someone says all they saw was the
word chopped so that's what Kody said so
that it closed no you daily got him
chopped is that what no it was like
usually it was basically about never it
doesn't but you talked about dying and
being on the road and let's uh how about
two more questions can we do two more
here Beth we're running over a little
[ __ ] we wrap this up do you land this
plane
cuz so all right we'll do one more and
this this could be a good memories one
because we are we're running the light a
little bit here kids so thank you to
everyone that posted questions oh dude I
said I would answer more concisely and I
didn't but it's all good
this one ties in to what we're just
talking about being on the
Road is a CJ asked what memories of the
road will flash through your mind right
before you die they will be III can
remember exactly where I was like in
Austin Texas at cap city a guy comes up
to me this was when I was touring that
joke about this joke about my mom we're
a show we did in LA it was cancelled and
she she's a teacher and she said snow
day and I have a joke about mom like you
know sweet if you're an I'm gonna tree
school teacher but if your comic they
think you got cooking and so she was
like and that I wrote that because a guy
came up to me and kept after a show in
cap city and was like um What did he say
oh my god I like you I wrote the joke
off of it I can't remember
do you like puck I forget what it was it
was something like do you ski or snow
sports or something it was basically
saying I thought he was asking me about
like some sort of does it snow where you
come I forget it was something like this
I didn't get it cuz I don't do drugs
and I was like what no is it he said
something about there's snow in Texas
and in my head I'm like it's arid like
what are we talking about here I was
like no and then he left and later some
he was like oh he's asking if you wanted
to do cocaine no clue and then later on
that my mom really did say snow day I
was able to link that joke but this I
can't believe it I've blanked on what he
said to me what was a guy coming up to
me after the show asking me if I do coke
you know he didn't say do you party it
was something to do with snow snow
skiing who cares the point is that
moment and then I was in a Madison
Wisconsin at comedy on state and this
was when I was selling like old albums I
guess I had hard albums and a guy was
like can you sign this for me I'm gonna
use it like he was basically saying I'm
gonna use it to jerk off with and his
wife was right there and she was like
top table
let's go or something like that but it
was just basically
come after me with his wife can you sign
this so I can use it later and it was
just like what he photos like just
anyway that um wait what was it saying
Oh moments on the road flashing before
my eyes trying to think of other oh um
Oh Gert uh there's this awesome chick
that came up to me after a show and
Indian I have like I said in this new
special there's abortion material and
she came up to buy a hat of mine my new
special is called girl daddy and I saw
these girl that he hats and she was like
I'm gonna wear this to my abortion next
week and she opened up her wallet and I
had like tons of cash in it and she was
like this is the money from the guy paid
for part of it that was an awesome
moment I talked about you know in this
new hour you know what it's like the
relationship between men and women and
sex and everyone's complaints and jokes
about the Miche movement and what it
really means involve also a guy in
indianapolis came up to me with his son
who was about to head off to college and
they were hammered and they were
together and they were like we got we
wanted my girl daddy hats it is like and
the guy the young guy was like a lot of
that stuff was really good for me to
hear thank you you know like this or
that it was just great it's a just a
great moment um basically me teaching
them about sex and just calm down and
and stop letting these male comics care
for you about it um I'm trying to think
I think this is a great moment
yeah those are awesome and they CJ says
lol girl daddy yeah Oh Cody says you
should write an illustrated kids book
about Nigel maybe merge merge they're
good yeah Nigel on the tail cornbread so
let's get to let's let's let this one be
where'd it go what are your opinions is
from Aaron deceiver and this could be
like yay or nay but what are your
opinions of the online open mics that
are happening you know and that's a good
question
I like to be honest I'm not really aware
of them like I think I knew that some of
them were happening like I got one email
for example from flappers comedy club
that was like I think initially during
ovid they were saying we're waiving the
fee and then they were like it's $5.00
per comic and it's like look this is an
interesting tough time as a touring
comic I have the ability to donate to
things like tip your waitstaff and clubs
that I've been to for the last year's of
headlining of people I care about
you know like Portland helium and all
the Vermont comedy club all these places
I I'm I'm not bragging about donating
I'm saying there's people there that I
care about and they need to make money
and it's a scary time so I'm happy to
donate however it's also a very
interesting time because there's a
complicated relationship between club
and comic when you first start you are
indebted to them you take the stage time
you need it you'll kind of say yes to
anything and really depending on the
club some of them are good and care but
it's a business and so oftentimes it can
feel like as a comic when you see how
much you can make versus how much you
started and it's a give-and-take
relationship you're nobody there giving
you a chance and as you build your
audience if you're a famous person you
can walk with an exorbitant amount of
money from a club so it's a complicated
relationship of feeling like they're
just robbing you less over time so when
you are being asked to pay for an open
mic it's kind of like to me I look at
that and I'm like oh [ __ ] that
so like that really bothers me because
it is so complicated when dented to you
but also you robbed me and it's like
it's it's it's frustrating because as an
artist like you are a commodity and you
can bring in more money at one point
then you put it in another point and so
I think I guess my point is it bothers
me when comics have to pay to do open
but I also understand that things are a
business and during these Kovach times
when comics who care about the clubs are
donating so the staff can be okay it's
kind of like I'm not a business owner so
I don't understand rent and how much
money they're losing on food but part of
me is also like why aren't you taking
care of them cuz we make a lot of money
it seems off of comics so like part of
me just wishes like the disparity
between what the people who work at the
club or being paid and how much the club
makes were during this time more I don't
know copasetic I worry about that but
anyway that was a long answer again
I open mics which is I'm not doing them
and I'm also not really doing zoom shows
because that's not stand-up comedy I you
know like it's just not I did disc lar
brothers like I'll riff with Mike for
the tip you wait step thing for Biglia
and I did the Sklar brothers just for
last show where you just have to do four
minutes of material but you're doing it
for the Sklar brothers and they're like
giggling with you and then you risk with
them four more minutes but that being
said I've also enjoyed watching some
comics performances so while it's not
for me like I don't really want to do
zoom shows I'm glad that other comics
are doing it if they feel that it's
right for them and they want to do it I
was watching some stuff that rosebud
Baker put out and it was making me laugh
so it's like you know so I'm glad some
people are doing it but um and I'm not
[ __ ] on it there's no right way for
any of this there's always gonna be
comics that say get up every night if
you're a real comic you'll grind and
then there are comics like you just go
up when they can it works for them so
just if I know what's right for you but
it bothers me if they're making you pay
to do the open mind yeah and speaking of
comics this question is do you think
Mike Birbiglia would do this show I
think Joel buyers posted that
this turn into a sketch that I did with
joke was all up where he was like I'm
gonna get some podcast and he's like you
know what there's some better people
than you that we're trying to get I'll
shoot his assistant your name I can I
appreciate that
yeah it's let's we're trying to do
something positive here for comedy you
know so I appreciate that
and as we we land this plane let's this
is one that can be answered in single
word raps we're gonna close strong here
and this is from I'm REE who asks who
are your [ __ ] top five favorite
comedians alive or dead Wow
growing up people I'm trying to think of
like it's interesting that people I
adored it and were influenced by our you
know comics they started as comics and
then turned more into actors so it Robin
Williams Eddie Murphy Jim Carrey Chris
Rock Whoopi Goldberg like those movies
were so formative to me as a young kid
so I'm naming those five because it's
like that's who I watched be funny and
be stars and imitate and emulate hmm
yeah so mostly men I mean you know I was
like III think about that because like
as a woman comic online but Whoopi my
loved and sister act I just think of
their movies or like Ace Ventura mrs.
Doubtfire these things I watched as a
kid that I I was I was just like yeah
down to earth with Chris Rock and um
anything anymore she wasn't his kid dr.
Doolittle even know that's something I
don't even think about like we we do a
daily writing Club in this group where
every day at 10:00 a.m. we meet up and
write for 10 minutes on a random word
just just to keep the the iron's sharp a
little bit and someone mentioned today
because I had emmy blotnick on earlier
this
week and now I'm having you on in a
female comic commented thank you for
proving that women are funny
and I'm just like it's that's not even
something I even like think about where
I'm like well I better get a female or
you know the streets are gonna revolt it
is just like there's just funny people
but you know it's almost like it's
almost like a weird thing that keeps
getting brought up it's odd it's it's
almost like it was made up I'm trying to
think of it I'm trying to get a grasp on
what I'm saying it's like if all of a
sudden for years every now and then
people just started saying like I guess
men can wear red it's like men are
wearing red they've been wearing red
it's like the turn of the century I'm so
confused why this keeps getting put out
I mean there have been lame a I mean
there have been lately cheval there have
been funny women entertaining like the
entire country for a very very long time
so it's almost like a odd thing that guy
like pushed through the vents or
something it doesn't make any sense yeah
it does so long I mean I I get the whole
look people love to sight Christopher
Hitchens and the evolutionary need to be
funny is not for women and you know men
needed to attract a mate and this for
that it's not but yeah woman they've
been funny forever but Twitter and
Instagram and all those things didn't
exist so we've really missed out on some
of the women who came and went in the
80s who were [ __ ] holding it down like
they just weren't big household names
Dooney come to mind you want to put on
shine
I hadn't heard Elaine May before so
that's someone I'm gonna check out yeah
I haven't heard of her before her it's
an old record but she was in a duo I'm
not gonna run it but um I mean somebody
like watch women of the night it's on
YouTube okay I'm gonna HBO special Lou's
Winstead's on there yeah I recommend
that perfect meetin some women who yeah
they just didn't it wasn't I think
sometimes there are we could all do a
better
job of sort of highlighting those women
but anybody from women of the night I
would say that's an easy search on
YouTube awesome alright so as let's get
out of here but do you have any this is
a comedy advice show so do you have any
closing comedy advice or wisdom favorite
anything favor you've picked up they has
helped you along the way you could
bestow upon us yeah I think you know it
takes time to find your voice I think
you'll notice when you are finally
really coming into yourself and your own
and do what you think is funny remember
that your words are a magnet so what you
say will draw certain people to you and
you need to make sure that those are the
type of people you want drawn to you you
don't have to do everything every
podcast you know like don't go on
something that has fans that you don't
think are gonna love what you do or you
don't want liking what you do not
everybody's gonna like you of course
there are comics that everybody likes
and they're a certain type of comic but
you have to decide what's right for you
and yeah well your jokes matter but I
think no matter who you are so to say
that you know to say things that whether
you're influential or not but especially
if you're influential and have a lot of
followers like they're not just jokes
like what you say matters so that's how
I how I see it
and yeah so where can people keep up and
support you as we're in quarantine here
anything you want to promote um you know
like I'm not like I kind of mentioned
this with you I'm not like putting out a
ton of content but you can always find
me at Beth Stelling on Instagram and
Twitter I you know I try to pop in here
and there but I'm writing on things so
I'm just sort of doing that and trying
to take this time to rest I mean I'm not
really doing shows or anything I'll play
equip lash every now and then which is
fun so I'll post I post about those
things and then in August my special is
set to come out on HBO max and it's
called girl daddy so
citing all right well thank you Beth
Stelling let's give her a round of
applause here have a sound effect we
play in the group I don't think you can
hear it on skype but everyone's hearing
applause right now so oh thank you thank
you for your time Beth hopper at the
verse go forth we'll be back next
Tuesday with a Shane Torres so until
then we'll have a good day hot breath
averse